the chancellor is promising a long
economic road to recovery from the
pandemic
as he raised taxes to their highest
level for decades in his budget
rishi sunac promised a further 65
billion pounds for employees and
businesses
to protect jobs and livelihoods of the
british people
but it is estimated that yesterday's
budget will lead to a million more
people paying
income tax and another million more
paying
at the 40 rate our chief political
correspondent john craig reports
a chancellor on the up after a spend now
tax later budget that has so far
received a favorable reaction
from conservative mps and in the first
post-budget opinion polls after pledging
to continue financial support for
workers and businesses
until after covert restrictions end
richie sunak paid tribute
to the victims of the pandemic to the
family and friends left behind
your loss felt most acutely in the
quietest of moments
must be overwhelming
but i promise you we will meet this
moment
with the passion and energy it demands
and we will build a fairer and more just
country
in their memory our recovery
begins today but labor claims mr sunak's
budget was a missed opportunity
because he said nothing about statutory
sick pay
and hasn't got the public health
response to covid wright
they should have been using it to back
the jobs of the future
to really support our key work our
heroes our nhs
and social care and to do far more to
support those who've become unemployed
i'm really sorry to say that in all
those cases
we simply did not see any measures from
government
as the chancellor himself had signaled
it was a budget of two halves
continuing emergency covered relief to
keep as many people as possible in a job
and tax rises but they won't begin to
bite until around the time of the next
general election
these are very big tax rises indeed it's
the biggest tax
raising budget since 1993 so in nearly
30
years and it will take if all delivered
are the tax burden in this country to
its highest level his highest
sustained level ever uh really
so this is quite a big deal the issue is
whether these will really happen
and since boris johnson plans to
announce the repeal of the fixed term
parliaments act
in the queen's speech in may the timing
of the chancellor's tax
rises suddenly makes an early general
election
more likely john craig skyny
i will let's speak to as i described him
the man himself the chancellor rishi
sunak joining us out from middlesbrough
great to see you this morning chancellor
um
in terms of the budget it strikes that
it was perhaps a kind of a tale of two
halves there was plenty
within it about the road to prosperity
one eye on the future
but also quite a bit on how we pay for
it we'll deal with the second in a sec
in a second but but just in terms of the
announcement on freeports which is
why you are standing where you are what
will these seven free ports be able to
do
that the eight that we shut down in 2012
were not
so what we announced yesterday neil were
eight free ports and eight
english regions across the country and
what freeports are they are special
economic zones
which have different rules that are
going to attract jobs investment and
trade to places
like t side where i'm now standing and
i'm incredibly excited about what this
means we said we would level up
opportunity across the country
freeports are an example of us doing
that it's a policy that we can now fully
pursue
in a unique british way now that we've
left the european union
and we've had great reaction to it we
had lots of people bidding to be
free ports and in areas like this where
steel was a fantastic industry of the
past and as we look forward
you know my my vision for the future of
a place like this is
teasport can be the place where we do
carbon capture and storage offshore wind
we're already manufacturing vaccines
here
all of that can happen inside of
freeport with special tax planning and
investment
and that's creating jobs across the
country so it's an exciting agenda
it certainly is but did you share any of
the eu's concerns when it comes to free
ports and the way that they can somehow
be used
sometimes be used to circumvent the tax
system i mean i don't know if you've
seen the film 10 it i have i understand
barely a word of it the one thing that
left out though
was the ability of highness of high
wealth individuals to use free ports to
conceal
some of their wealth well actually free
ports are used extensively
across the world and the eu is actually
one of the few places that doesn't use
them
extensively everywhere else does for
example in america there are over 200 of
them employing
close to half a million people and of
course all free ports and especially the
ones
here in britain will be ones which we
agree with all the oecd rules
around tax and making sure that customs
facilitations all happen
in an orderly manner following all the
rules so i don't think anyone has
anything to worry about on that
uh front but what they will do is
attract businesses to locate with the
tax incentives
invest in in new equipment new plants
here create jobs in places like t-side
or southampton or liverpool
and i think that's exciting um can we
talk then about
the freezing of personal tax thresholds
and and to your credit you did not shy
away at the dispatch box yesterday for
spelling out
exactly what this will mean to people i
mean you couldn't have done much more
short of wearing a baseball cap with
this will cost you money written on it
and everyone understands that we all
have our part to play in
in getting the nation's economy back on
track but at the same time isn't it
pretty clear that if everyone who is
paying tax will have to pay
more in tax the people who will feel
that most keenly
are those who have leased to start with
so in terms of the budget yesterday neil
i think you alluded this in your intro
i think the first part of the budget was
to make good on the promise that we
would do whatever it takes
to protect people and businesses through
the remaining stages of this crisis
and the budget announced an enormous
amount of extra support for example
extending furlough through to september
lots more cash support for businesses as
we exit the restrictions
that's the right thing to do now and
that's why we did that yesterday but i
also wanted to be honest with people
honest with the country about the
challenges that coronavirus
has caused us particularly in our public
finances
and i don't think it would be right or
straight to ignore those
let them be someone else's problem to
fix which is why we set out a plan to
address that
but importantly the steps in that plan
don't don't
come into it they don't come into effect
straight away and they protect public
services and working people
but there's a question of priorities in
all this which was what i was alluding
to in the questions why we're choosing
to balance this off the back of
of everyone rather than for example the
huge number of high net worth
individuals who have done pretty well
out of this pandemic why is
why someone for example i mean what what
one particular one of the
estimates uh and there are plenty in the
paper so please challenge of it it's
wrong
but if you're earning 11 and a half
thousand pounds now by 25 26 inflation
could mean
you're earning a salary of 13 and a half
thousand pounds you'll go from paying no
income
tax to paying 186 pounds now i
understand to you and me that might mean
the price of a coffee mug
to other people that's the cost their
kids shoes for the year
so actually freezing personal tax
thresholds neil
is a progressive way to raise money i
think crucially what people need to
understand
is no one's current take-home pay that
they have today
is affected or lowered by this policy
what it does do is remove the
incremental benefit
that they might have experienced in the
future as inflation fed through to their
wages but their current cash take-home
pay isn't affected
and also crucially those on higher
incomes
are affected more by this policy it's a
very progressive policies
and that's something that has been noted
by independent
think tanks that are respected like the
institute for fiscal studies
uh and others who have who have made the
point that those
the richest 20 of households for example
will end up contributing i think about
15 times more
than those on the lowest incomes that's
why this is a fair way
to help solve the problems that we need
to but crucially no one's cash take home
pay is affected and it doesn't come into
force
just now because we want to support the
recovery in the short term as we are
doing
sure there will be those who agree that
it is progressive surely it would have
been made more progressive by the fact
that
if you had for example protected those
at the bottom end
not stuck a freeze on them i mean we're
talking about a million more people
paying tax which is a significant
increase we're talking about perhaps a
million more people
million and 1.3 million perhaps paying
at the 40 percent rate i mean that
includes teachers
nurses plenty of people like that how
would you describe people
who will be on that 40 uh tax rate would
you describe them as well off
you talked first of all about people on
on lower incomes i think it's important
to remember our personal allowance
at just over 12 and a half thousand
pounds
is by far and away the most generous
personal allowance anywhere in the g20
group of large uh countries
so we start from the position that that
is already the most approach to the most
generous approach to those on lowest
incomes out of basically any other major
country in the world
we've doubled that personal allowance
over the last 10 years
saving those on lower incomes over a
thousand pounds
and also the other things that we're
doing to help people on low incomes for
example increasing the national living
wage
from april of this year above inflation
at a difficult time
but that's because we want to support
those on lower incomes and that will
mean
a pay rise of around 350 pounds
for someone working full-time on the
national living wage starting in april
so we do remain committed to that and we
start
in a strong place with the highest most
generous personal allowances pretty much
anywhere else you can find
it is a common theme of interviews with
particularly conservative chancellors
but with chancellors to ask them to to
rule out tax rises now given that this
freeze you as announced in the budget
yesterday
is due to be in place until 2025 2026 i
wonder if we can turn it on its head
can you promise that there will be no
income tax
cuts this site of the next election
all right well what what what i am what
i'm going to say is we're just talking
about this budget for now
neil and and in terms of this budget
you're right why i made something
yes we talked about we talked about what
we took yeah but we talked about the
allowance freeze
and then the other decision we made is
to ask large companies in two years time
to also
play their part in helping us fix the
problem and i made those choices
as i explained yesterday specifically
because i wanted to protect working
people from
increases in their tax rates so we
honored our manifesto commitment not to
increase
the rates of tax on national insurance
income tax
or vat that was important me to do and
we also wanted to crucially protect
public services
and protect small businesses and that's
why i believe the two measures we set
out yesterday
they are the right measures they're fair
and they will support our economic
recovery
sure just in terms of the corporation
tax rise from 19 to 25 percent over the
over the next few years um i mean does
this you basically turned
a kind of a decade of conservative
orthodoxy on corporation tax on its head
we've been told that
you know if you raise cooperation to
actually restrict growth if you cut it
you
increase growth i mean is this the end
of the party's obsession with with the
laffer curve i mean certainly there are
plenty of businesses this morning
that are not laughing
well if you look at our corporation tax
rate it's important that it's
internationally competitive neil
so even after this increase we will
still have the lowest corporation tax
rate
of of what's called the g7 countries the
large economies that we
compete with around the world america
canada germany
italy france so we will have a lowest
corporation tax rate even after this
increase compared to all of them
we are also exempting small businesses
we're protecting them
from the increase so 70 of businesses
won't be affected by the increase at all
we want to protect small business and
also we want to support business in the
short term
to invest and help drive our recovery so
what i announced yesterday was something
called the super deduction
it's a tax cut for business investment
the likes of which we've never tried
before in this country
and i'm hopeful that it will spur
businesses to invest
in new free ports like t-side where i am
today as we've discussed
and that will help drive our recovery
create jobs and support businesses to do
exactly that
completely understand that but of all
this sme owners that have been in touch
with me over the past 24 hours and there
have been plenty of them
the one point that all of them make is
this what about those
big companies the tech giants that have
done
exceptionally well out of all of this i
mean amazon
google facebook twitter these these big
organizations where has been the focus
on them in all of this they've done
incredibly well
and frankly some of them won't even be
paying five percent tax
on their earnings so neil remember
corporation tax is a tax on profits
so by definition businesses that are
doing well and making profits pay
pay a good amount of tax uh which is as
it should be but you're right to
highlight
online companies now and the reality is
the way our tax system works it makes it
difficult to tax these large
global tech companies which is why in
last year's budget
i introduced something called the
digital services tax
where we've levied a percentage charge
on their
turnover because we can't tax them in
the way that we would like to
that's already taking force and what we
are doing now
is working with our international
partners around the world
we are in charge of something called the
g7 group this year so i'm leading that
charge with finance ministers around the
world
to reach an international agreement on
how to tax these large
tech companies properly because that
involves all of us to agree a set of
rules
so we can we can approach it in a common
way but in the short term we have got a
digital services tax which is doing
exactly what you
you've suggested and we will replace
that with an international agreement
hopefully this year
as we work with our other partners at
the heart though of this budget pitch
was was this claim
and it has been made a number of times
over the course of the pandemic by you
and a number of other cabinet ministers
that you'll do whatever it takes to help
the british people
uh through this crisis where was the
support for for the excluded yesterday
we understand that yep those who are
recently self-employed
will be pretty pleased that there will
be an opportunity for them to get some
more money of course after 12 months of
not getting anything
but paye freelancers limited company
directors
those denied furlough they're still not
recognized i'm sorry to kind of bang on
about this but i just want to read you a
couple of tweets that we've had
chris davis is the director of a limited
company he says this
i can't even begin to explain the anger
i'm feeling right now i'm so angry i'm
shaking i've lost my wife my kids
my house my business my savings i'm done
stephen gray was on the show yesterday
what do you suggest to someone excluded
because they earned a tad over 50k
before the pandemic
but is now down to 80 and still excluded
what should they do
to put food on the table that the mantra
that you have done everything you could
to help everyone who is in need of help
is demonstrably untrue chancellor
so so neil i i couldn't hear all the
details of everything you said
but what i would say is we made a major
improvement in access to our
self-employment
scheme yesterday it was frustrating last
year we we weren't able to bring in
newly self-employed people because we
they hadn't all filed their tax returns
now that the tax return deadline has
passed we were able to announce that all
those people it will be more than 600
000
new people will be able to benefit from
the fourth and fifth self-employment
grants
uh that will be in place over the coming
months that's good news
and welcome and i appreciate that people
haven't felt that they've been able to
get the help they want in exactly the
way they want in the time they want but
this is only one element of the support
that we've put in place
so for example we've talked already
about universal credit
support with people's rent through
something called local housing allowance
mortgage holidays bounce loans a support
that we've given to local authorities
that they can use at their discretion to
support
their local businesses so there's lots
of different things that we are doing
and if you take a step back and you look
at the budget but yesterday what it
shows is that over the course of this
crisis
we will have spent over 30 billion
pounds
supporting those who are in
self-employment and i i'm confident that
that will stand as one of the most
generous approaches to supporting
self-employed people
anywhere in the world which is great to
have you on the show this morning thanks
for being with us
thank you neil take care
let's speak to our political
correspondent rob powell lurking in the
wings
um rob i suppose the problem for the
chancellors is pretty straightforward
no chancellor can please everybody all
of the time but come
budget day and come budget day in the
middle of a pandemic where lots and lots
of people haven't been earning
there is a laser sharp focus on those
who perhaps haven't been assisted and
those who are going to lose
out yeah and i think what you're seeing
from the chancellor there is him
sort of struggling to reconcile the fact
that he wants to be a conservative
chancellor
who cuts taxes with the fact that the
tax burden when all of these
changes go through will be the highest
since 1969.
the overnight reviews anyway feel like
he's maybe just about doing it but i
think he's only doing it because he's
perhaps
not being completely honest about the
massive uncertainty built into some of
the measures that he announced yesterday
not least
whether the corporation tax hike will
actually take as much as they plan to do
remember the last 10 years as you
pointed out
we've been told that cutting corporation
tax actually increases tax receipts
because you get more business activity
they are spending a lot of money on this
super deduction
without much cast iron evidence of
whether that will actually lead to new
investment or just bringing
investment forward free ports as well
where he was today that's something of a
gamble
and it's all set against a backdrop
which is very uncertain
as well if interest rates go up the debt
repayments on the
for the government will rise by 25
billion if just just a one percent
um increase and there's nothing in there
for the added strain on public services
from 2022 going forward
on things like the nhs catch up in
education in school so
i think the the chancellor's probably
done a very deft political balancing act
whether he's being fully honest
about the picture in the round is
another story though rob many thanks
indeed
uh of course the day after budget day
plenty to come on the program at half
past seven uh the dg of the cbi will be
here to chat about the budget
corporation tax rates rising to as much
as
25 bet they'll have a view
uh nicholas sturgeon yesterday told an
inquiry that alex salmon's claims to a
plot against him
were absurd we'll be chatting through
her evidence with the
leader of the scottish conservatives
douglas ross at 20 to eight
then at five past eight we'll be joined
by the shadow chancellor annelise
dodds after labour said rishi sunak's
budget was just
tapering over the cracks
uh buckingham palace has begun
investigating claims that the duchess of
sussex
bullied royal staff following reports
that megan faced a bullying complaint
when she was a working royal
the duke and duchess for their part say
they are victims of a smear campaign and
that the allegations
are based on misleading and harmful
information
science ali fortescue has the report
harry and megan pride themselves on
philanthropy and service
[Applause]
but new allegations claim that some
staff at kensington palace were bullied
and reduced to tears by the duchess of
sussex
the rights of women and girls is
something that's very close to my heart
just days before the couple's tell-all
interview with oprah
their representatives strongly deny the
allegations
lawyers for the couple told the times
that this was a calculated smear
campaign
based on misleading and harmful
misinformation
i was completely shocked i mean one knew
that something was up one knew that she
could be a demanding boss
one knew it wasn't all smooth sailing in
the palace
but to hear these stories to hear them
first hand uh
i was quite taken aback bucky and palace
say they're very concerned by the
allegations which will be looked at by
their hr team they said that members of
staff involved at the time including
those who've left the household will be
invited to participate to see if
lessons can be learned the royal
household they said had a dignity at
work policy
in place for a number of years it does
not and will not tolerate bullying or
harassment
in the workplace this all goes back to a
time where the sussexes were sharing an
office here at kensington palace with
the duke and duchess of cambridge and at
the heart of this
is an email that was sent by one of the
couple's most senior advisers saying
that he was unhappy
with the way that megan was treating
several members of staff
but those concerns were never pursued
and they were never formalized
a buckian palace source told us that
they are staggered by the allegation
that the palace is creating a smear
campaign
against the couple spokesperson for the
sussexes said that the duchess is
saddened by this latest attack on her
character
particularly as someone who's been the
target of bullying herself
and is deeply committed to supporting
those who've experienced
pain and trauma megan and i met god in
2013.
nick eid has worked closely with megan
he finds it hard to believe the claims
yeah i think the royal family are
probably you know it's quite archaic
and the way that uh the royal family has
had a tradition for so many years
and protocols that they have and things
they put in place potentially somebody
like a big breath of fresh air like
megan
who comes in and has different attitudes
towards things i doubt whether
megan would ever be somebody who would
sort of chastise anybody within the
royal family
or anybody who was working for her i
suspect it was probably lost in
translation
all of this is playing out as a duke of
edinburgh spends his 16th night in
hospital
his daughter-in-law said he's improving
[Music]
i just want to make it clear to
everybody there
is no subject that's off limit but all
eyes are on the sussexes just days until
they tell their side of the story
harry and megan are once again facing
accusations of acrimony in the royal
household
ali forskou sky news
hmm uh well overnight the first extracts
of the duchess of sussex
speaking to oprah about how the couple
were treated by the palace
have been released uh let's have a chat
with our correspondent enda brady who's
in the newsroom and
you've seen it what does she say well
we'll take a listen now in a moment neil
it's about 40 seconds long it's the
second promotional clip that has been
released by the american broadcaster it
is the duchess speaking for the first
time
she's speaking to oprah winfrey and we
can listen now
how do you feel about the palace hearing
you speak your truth today
i don't know how they could expect
that after all of this time we would
still just be silent
if there is an active role that the firm
is playing
in perpetuating falsehoods about us and
if that comes with risk of losing things
i mean i've
there's a lot that's been lost already
and of course this interview was
recorded before
those bullying allegations surfaced in a
prominent newspaper yesterday morning
the palace
investigating megan says that she has
done nothing wrong and that she has been
the victim of bullying over many years
so
it will be broadcast on sunday night in
the united states and in this country on
monday evening
ender many thanks indeed
also this morning a prototype rocket has
exploded
uh just minutes after bosses declared a
perfect touchdown and the spacex
starship flew more than
six miles before returning to land
perfectly
only to explode a few moments later
it is the third landing here's the
explosion itself
it's the third landing attempt to end in
a fireball as the company tries to
develop a rocket which
could take humans to mars
an extra 1 million people are set to
start paying income tax in the next five
years
according to official forecasts due to a
move announced by the chancellor in his
budget yesterday
a little earlier on the program mr sunak
defended the decision
to freeze income tax rates claiming it
would mainly affect the richest 20
of households freezing personal tax
thresholds neil
is a progressive way to raise money i
think crucially what people need to
understand
is no one's current take-home pay that
they have today
is affected or lowered by this policy
what it does do is remove the
incremental benefit
that they might have experienced in the
future as inflation fed through to their
wages but their current cash take-home
pay isn't affected
and also crucially those on higher
incomes
are affected more by this policy it's a
very progressive policy the richest 20
of households for example will end up
contributing i think about 15 times more
than those on the lowest incomes that's
why this is a fair way
to help solve the problems that we need
to
well as well as personal finances excuse
me
yesterday's budget contained a huge
number of tax reforms for big business
corporation taxes we've been hearing
will rise
but the chancellor has introduced a
so-called super deduction
allowing businesses to offset investment
spending
let's get some reaction to that uh we're
joined now by the director general of
the confederation of british industry
tony danker tony
uh great to have you on the program this
morning um
bearing in mind uh ofcom rules about
colorful language i wonder what your
immediate reaction was when you heard
business
at rates we've got a business actually
going up from 19 to 25
yeah i think there was a sharp intake of
breath look
let's be clear uh it was a really good
budget for the short run
a soft landing rather than a crash
landing for firms coming out of the
crisis i think the chancellor over
delivered there for many firms
and also a really big boost as you said
to business investment in the next two
years something i've talked to the
chancellor about
several times in the last few months and
again really bold action there
look as for the big hike in corporation
tax
i think most business people i speak to
strongly believe that we are going to
need to raise taxes to
pay off the debt from the pandemic and
that businesses should
pay their fair share i think that idea
of an
overnight hike from 19 to 25
is a bit of a shock and it raises really
questions about the uk's competitiveness
in the medium term you know we're coming
off the back of a post-covid
post-brexit era the most important thing
we do in the next 10 years is be
competitive as a country
and so yes some concern about that but i
think people accept the need to pay tax
uh to pay off the debt that comes from
the crisis uh in in terms though and
it appears in the chancellor's mind have
been balanced out by the by the super
deduction announcement
uh trying to increase the amount of
investment in the uk
i suppose though on that topic the key
question is whether or not this is going
to generate new investment
or whether it's just going to drag
investment forward
well i think it will probably do both
speaking to a few tax experts yesterday
i think they felt it would indeed do a
good job of as you say
bringing investment forward and by the
way that is what we need
i mean as you probably know britain's
been pretty bad at business investment
for the last few decades
i do think there is an opportunity now
we're doing really well on vaccination
people are keen to put the crisis behind
us
we had a lot of uncertainty for four or
five years over brexit so i do think it
is a pretty unique moment
to really go for it when it comes to
business investment
and that's why i think the chancellor is
bravely experimenting with this idea of
a super deduction
but you're right there is a risk that
you bring forward lots of investment and
then all of a sudden in two years time
you have a sudden hike which curtails it
so we're gonna have to be attentive to
that but i i certainly don't criticize
him for
bringing forward business investment now
is the time to get the economy roaring
again
still tony you you will know as as well
as anyone that some of the
the businesses that have done best
during the pandemic are
some of those multinationals that
frankly pay precious little tax
here in this country and the small
business owners that i spoke to
yesterday
were of one mind in all of this say look
we understand you know we've been
running our profit we're going to have
to pay more
out of that particular pot but what
about the big guys
who have you know profits in excess of
what profits in the tens of billions
and their corporation tax burden is
is minimal
yeah look i i think we need to be
careful uh
when when we say that i think there are
thousands of companies who pay
top rate corporation tax they are the
people who create
tons and tons of jobs and revenue for
the exchequer
the chancellor wouldn't be targeting
them if he didn't think it would bring
in what it will bring in which is 17
billion pounds
in addition so this is not just a small
number of companies making supernatural
profits
this is most of the large companies in
the country and also by the way
it is also small growing companies who
need to choose where they're going to
locate themselves britain or other
jurisdictions
so we have to be attentive to whether or
not britain is a competitive
jurisdiction
uh for tax and by the way it's not just
corporation tax it's
very very high almost world beating
business rates which make the british
environment
uh not always as competitive as we might
think so
i i understand why people have
particular
concerns about particular companies but
we're going to have a lot of british
businesses who are very large employers
that make up a lot of the
national economy paying higher business
rates
paying higher corporation tax it's not
just the story of a few exceptional
companies
that is indeed the case tony great to
have your views this morning thanks for
joining us
and now let's turn on rotation our
attention to myanmar
funerals taking place there this morning
following the worst day of violence
since the military coup 38 people were
killed
and protests are continuing today skies
southeast asia correspondent
siobhan robbins joining us now i mean
siobhan i suspect i know the answer to
this question but what hope that the
the death the violence will come to an
end anytime soon
i don't think it will come to an end any
time soon and i think the level of
brutality that we saw
in various places around the country
yesterday
show that if anything since sunday when
we saw a particularly violent day
as well the crackdown has become
stricter by the authorities so for
example yesterday among those killed was
a 19 year old
she was shot in the head in mandalay her
family are burying her today also
reports a 14 year old
was killed i also saw some very
distressing images
that we can't show you of a man
appearing to be shot at
point-blank range and some of the
footage that we're just about to show
you a warning this is
very distressing and it is violent uh
does show you what appears to be
soldiers
beating medics over the head as well so
really
really um distressing and widespread
scenes of violence but it hasn't put
protesters off they are back on the
streets again
i think the worry is that some people
were hoping that the international
community and the pressure they could
put on
those generals that have led the coup
might mean that they
moved away from a more brutal crackdown
but an update from
the unm boy who has spoken to people
within that gender organization seems to
remove
some of that hope this is what she told
reporters last night
i warned them that member states and
security council might
take huge strong measures
and the answer was we are used to
sanctions
and we we survived those
sanctioned time in the past
the worry there is if the generals and
those in charge of the country don't
care about sanctions they don't care
what the international community thinks
then the concern will be they will
continue down this route they will
continue
to crack down on the streets until they
get the type of myanmar
they believe they need nicholas sturgeon
the first minister of scotland of course
has denied being part of a plot to
remove her predecessor alex salmond
calling the claims absurd as she gave
evidence at a hollywood inquiry
but she did admit that her government
had made serious mistakes in its
investigation into complaints
against him uh joining us now the leader
of the scottish conservatives douglas
ross mr ross very good morning
to you hopefully we should have you in
just one second
ah we don't have uh mr ross for the time
being
uh well let's instead um speak to alan
taylor former deputy and
managing editor at the scotsman writer
of a biography
on alex salmond and i'm sure someone who
has a a few views on what's been going
on ah
great alan thank goodness the journal
the former journalist can turn up in the
politician count we got that one right
um tell us just a little bit about your
view of what we learned if anything
um from nicholas sturgeon's evidence to
the inquiry yesterday
well i think her defense of her own
position was very robust
and very eloquent very passionate i
think she's maintained from the
beginning that she had done nothing
wrong
i think she was clear that the
government had made some missteps along
the way
but nevertheless there's no reason why
nicolas sturgeon for example
should think about resigning at the
particular moment um
so i think that uh she came out of it
very well yesterday actually i think
that
um she defended her position extremely
well i i suppose the key phrase there is
is at the particular moment i mean we're
still of course awaiting the
the conclusions of this inquiry we're
awaiting the conclusions of the inquiry
into
potential breach of the ministerial code
i mean certainly on the latter
having hired an independent investigator
if that comes back
as critical of the first minister surely
at that point our position begins to
approach untenable
well i think the key thing is to wait
for the end for the report to
to to be made public and i think too
many people have been bellicose
in the interim making as much political
capital as they possibly can about this
i think we do have to wait for the
report to be published and if it is
damning for miss sturgeon then we'll
have to wait and see what her decision
will be about her future
but that's the key thing we need to wait
for this report to be actually published
and the intimations at the moment are
that
some politicians are prepared to wait
for the report to be published i was
listening to
the green msp earlier today patrick
harvey
and he was suggesting i think that he is
not going to make any statements now
about mr sturgeon's future until he
hears what the report says
i mean we can we can always park the
kind of um the calls for
nicholas sturgeon's resignation to the
side for for a decent amount of time
but if we look at what happened at the
inquiry yesterday it wasn't just jackie
bailly that was complaining about the
disclosure or lack thereof
on the part of the scottish government
it was the snp convener of the committee
itself
i mean clearly time and again the
scottish government has resisted
uh resisted any attempt to to
to put them in the position where they
had to publish and then they found
themselves in a position where they've
had to publish
yeah these are complicated legal matters
now i don't think many of us understand
this
um it's a bit like the schleswig
palestine question nobody remembers what
the question actually was now
things have happened so fast and that
changed as the days go by
but i think that um the government have
um
resisted this i'm not exactly sure why
whether they were taking legal advice or
not i don't know i don't think many of
us actually know
but now that we are getting the material
published
now is the time for us to sit back calm
down
read the report and come to our
conclusions then
whether the snp in all of this i mean to
have
two of the most totemic two not the two
most atemic
figures in the snp's history essentially
at loggerheads former friends
falling out so publicly i mean at the
very least one can the very least one
can say is this hardly lends
weight to the cause of independence
well family feuds are never good you
know um i don't think voters in general
uh like uh political parties to be
arguing with themselves
that's for sure um and i think um this
has been an unseemly affair from
from the beginning however um who knows
what effect it will have for example in
the elections of may
and independence in the long term i
think wiser voters
are more interested in the issues and
the cause than they are and the
personalities
but the indications seem to be neil that
voters
are pretty much sticking with the snp
and pretty much sticking with
independence recent polls don't show
very much
diminution diminution and support for
the snp
so we'll have to wait for a few weeks to
see really
what the effect has been but i think at
the moment
people are by and large sticking with
the snp
they're not impressed by the official
opposition in hollywood
the tories and when they actually make
these bellicose statements
calling for resignations calling for no
votes of no confidence
because all one has to do is look south
to westminster
and see a government that has broken
international law
uh has pro-rolled parliament has refused
to get rid of a chief advisor when he
breaks
covert regulations and we look at the
personal life for example of the prime
minister
well alan you might want to stay where
you are and listen to our next interview
i think it might be of some interest
alan taylor great to have you on the
program this morning
um let's turn our attention uh to the
man who has been calling
for that vote of no confidence calling
for the resignation of the first
minister william
scottish conservatives is joining us uh
from just down the road uh
douglas ross great to see you this
morning um i i wondered mr ross if you
might want to respond
to that which alan taylor was just
saying there that that all these calls
for nicholas sturgeon's head
at the very least somewhat premature
given that the inquiries which are
looking into the mishandling of the alex
salmond
allegations the other one that's looking
into the the breach of the ministerial
court neither of them have yet to
conclude
well it's because the evidence is
compelling and what we have seen in the
last few days
is multiple witnesses backing up the
accusations
that mean nicholas sturgeon has lied and
misled the scottish parliament
but alan was saying there that votes of
no confidence
aren't achieving anything it was only
the threat that we still have on the
table of a vote of no confidence in john
swinney
that led the legal advice being released
to the inquiry legal advice that the
inquiry
s p led inquiry have asked for
parliament has twice voted for that the
snp
refused to release so it's only because
we take this action that we're any
closer to getting to the truth
sure but i suspect there will be people
who alan taylor are amongst them
uh suggesting that you know calling for
the first minister's head for
at the very most the very most that
could be proved is that she misled
parliament and she
she denies that she did so you know
you've had cabinet colleagues
conservative cabinet colleagues down
here breaching international law the
home secretary of all people
uh breaching the ministerial code and
then the prime minister having to step
in and say well actually
by the way i look at it it doesn't for
you to be calling for the first
minister's head when so many people
around that cabinet table
in many people's eyes probably shouldn't
be in their jobs right now it seems a
bit rich
well let's look at what the snp did in
2001 when they called for unsuccessfully
it saw an uh labour first minister
resigned from office at the time john
swinney said the people of scotland
would be staggered at the amount of
money involved
at that time it was thirty six thousand
pounds over the sublet of henry
mcleish's office
now we're speaking about hundreds of
thousands of pounds more than half a
million pounds
in a legal bid that the snp continued to
pursue when their own lawyers were
telling them it was doomed to failure
doesn't doesn't doesn't all that prove
is that you're all as bad as each other
that you all participate in this
hypocrisy from time to time calling for
some people's heads and then defending
the people who are in your own party
well i don't defend everyone within my
own party i know
alan was we were speaking about the
dominic cummings visit i resigned from
government over dominic cummings and his
trip to barnard castle but what i
wouldn't stand by for is a first
minister that has lied to the scottish
parliament and the people of scotland
and we know that now because multiple
witnesses
people from within her own party are
confirming that she knew about the
allegations against alex salmon before
she
previously said she did i mean one of
those who've been getting in touch this
morning on twitter and they've been
quite a lot whenever
scottish politics comes up my twitter
mention seemed to come alive for some
reason
can you ask douglas ross this why does a
woman need to apologize for a man's
actions in terms of nicolas sturgeon
are being asked to apologize for for
alex salmon
but then again you know but matt hancock
isn't held
to the same kind of level of
accountability
well myrtle fraser was looking at the
scottish government and the mistakes
made by the scottish government which
nicola sturgeon
leads mistakes that have cost over five
hundred thousand pounds and of course we
now know
that one of the complainants who went to
the scottish government to raise serious
allegations against alexander her
details were shared with his team
and we got no further forward in terms
of finding out how that
despicable act was allowed to happen
yesterday so women are at the heart of
this
and for their benefit we need to get to
the bottom of this and the truth and we
didn't get any closer to that yesterday
with nicolas sturgeon's evidence
so what is then at the next move for
opposition parties in scotland there's
no confidence what's going nowhere
well our no confidence vote in john
swinney remains because although they
have released some of the legal advice
they wrote to the committee
very quickly after nicolas sturgeon
finished an eight-hour evidence session
yesterday
offering more evidence and they will
release more documents this week so we
will look at that
and we have lodged the motion of no
confidence in nicolas surgeon because
the evidence is clear it's damning she's
misled parliament she has to resign
douglas ross great to having the show
this morning thanks for being with us
time to see how the weather is looking
we know from mr ross that the weather's
not too bad at just outside parliament
but what about the rest of us here's
isabel
thanks neil actually yeah this time next
week the weather's looking very
different much windier much
wetter really quite miserable but today
it's fairly quiet i suppose a lot of
cloud around let's take a look at the
detail
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
it's a cloudy start some rain around as
well but we do have a front that's
pushing southwards clearing the far
southwest tonight
and we've got broken clouds following
which does mean that there'll be an
improvement in the weather
and it could well be quite sunny for
many tomorrow with some fine weather
lasting into the weekend as well
more frost at night mind you but out
there this morning it is mostly frost
free across
many parts of the country and as you can
see there's a lot of cloud around low
cloud in the south
giving rather gloomy conditions again
with some patchy drizzly rain
we also have some rain in other parts
too but it does look as though it'll
become drier
and clearer across scotland as the day
goes on that clearer weather with some
sunshine
filtering down into the northeast of
england before the end of the afternoon
elsewhere though as you can see pretty
cloudy the rain pushes through tonight
though giving us a frost tonight
but hopefully a very nice start to
friday with some sunshine
the weather sponsored by qatar airways